[Music]
the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
not that you needed a reminder that
republicans don't really care about debt
and deficit but the federal government
incurred the biggest monthly budget
deficit in the history
of the united states as a country in
june
and of course i mean listen in this case
we know why
right we we've been seeing the budget
deficit go up under trump anyway
in june it was high because of the
spending on the coronavirus
relief programs and at the same time the
job losses mean that the government is
taking in
less money when it comes to tax revenue
but the treasury department reported um
on monday yesterday that the deficit was
864 billion dollars last month
month understand and that is larger
than the annual deficits that we've had
for most of our history
in a month we had a bigger deficit so
you know i mean when we talk about this
pat
i think it's important to remember that
deficit and debt is just a political
football
and i would say republicans more than
democrats but both parties use it as a
political football
in this particular case we have a very
specific understanding as to why it was
this high and it's one word it's
coronavirus
sure and if hillary clinton was
president she also would be running
really high deficits right now
you mentioned the political football
point i mean i think republicans tend to
make more of an issue out of it than
democrats do particularly when democrats
are in charge right that was a key
attack they had against obama look at
the debt look at the debt
of course they ignored the fact that he
uh cut the deficit in half which is
really what the president has control
over
uh and you know obama heritage inherited
such a mess with what bush gave him sure
but like i i love going back to those
times i love i love
bringing that up to consider whatever it
is about how you complain so much about
the debt and the deficit
and look at trump even before
coronavirus it skyrocketed under him and
then you shut up about it you don't care
about it anymore what happened i love
bringing up that point
what do they actually say because i've
not had that many opportunities to even
see i mean i just i don't know of
prominent republicans who have been
confronted with that i think
now they would say well it's because of
coronavirus but of course that's only
been the case for the last four or five
months
exactly that's why i like bring it up
because they never have anything good to
say it's always moving on to the next
issue or whatever i suppose they could
say well trump rebuilt the military and
that's why
uh but it's not like our military it
wasn't shambles before that's what i
mean so in other words
they would respond they would deflect by
lying about something which was that our
military was in rough shape
when obama left which of course is not
true yeah and i can
of course double down on the point about
how uh trump uh cut taxes
and didn't pay for it apparently the tax
cuts were going to pay for themselves
and that never happened
and so without cutting things like you
know medicare and social security these
other things
uh that they often talk about of course
we're going to run
massive debts massive deficits and you
know this this problem has gotten much
much worse under trump if you think of
it as a problem and this is coming from
the guy who had promised to uh
cancel the entire national debt in two
terms the only thing i'm worried about
rhetorically like obviously you and i
know that it's [ __ ]
but i worry how many of trump's
followers will
fall for using coronavirus as the reason
why
promises weren't kept and i'll give like
so i'll give you some examples trump
said he was going to
replace obamacare obviously after three
months of trump being in office it was
clear he wasn't going to
now he could say listen we had a medical
crisis that's not the time to go and
replace obamacare even though they've
actually still been trying during the
virus
to continue short-circuiting parts of
obamacare the wall
trump said by the end of the first term
the entire wall was going to be built
across the u.s mexico border
instead it looks like they're going to
have repaired a couple hundred miles or
something like that trump can say
listen i was dealing with coronavirus
will his followers accept that
explanation
well i feel like there's there's two
ways to counter that one you can take a
look at how things were before the
coronavirus started
sure about how you know the debt and
deficit was up about how like the wall
wasn't being built
all that stuff so if you want to go back
in time to that point uh like the very
beginning of this year
you can do that uh but i i think back to
the conversation that sean hannity had
with mark cuban
um and sean hannity was like listing off
trump's accomplishments before
coronavirus and mark cuban
astutely pointed out to him you don't
get a mulligan i mean you're responsible
for everything that happens under your
presidency you have to deal with it
you don't just get to say oh if if it
wasn't for coronavirus trump would be
such a great president it doesn't work
that way that's like
saying like what how would how would
obama do without the great recession
like that was a big thing that happened
at the beginning of his term especially
he had to fight through that he has to
deal with that that's the real world
that's what we live in
but i guess i'm thinking that's what
someone like mark cuban would reply but
if trump says it to his followers
there's not going to be anybody there
necessarily to interject some of those
counterpoints his followers might just
say
were it not for coronavirus this would
have been the most success
successful presidential term ever yeah i
don't know exactly what they say and
it's
of course going to depend on the the
trump supporter but like i feel like
because they always give these like
contradictory
rationalizations and trump himself can't
actually argue the points he always has
to deflect
i don't think they're so prepared to
deal with it either um and so yeah like
sometimes they just try to come up with
like a cure-all phrase like the trump
derangement syndrome thing because i
don't think they can argue this stuff
like point by point
certainly they're not choosing to that's
for sure and we'll see what happens in
the next three and a half months
one of the last places i would be caught
right now
is an amusement park disney world
in orlando florida has made a huge deal
out of the fact that they are reopening
now what's completely crazy
is that if florida were a country it
would be one of the worst
countries in the world to be in from the
standpoint of coronavirus
and disney world is opening and what's
crazy
is not only are they opening some people
are actually going which is a whole
other thing we're going to talk about
but a lot of people are complaining
about how it's uncomfortable to have
your mask on the whole day
at disney world so they have now
reportedly opened a bunch of designated
areas
called um relaxation zones
where you don't have to wear your mask
while you are in that zone
this is all such a [ __ ] show and at this
like is it an emergency to go to
to disney world now i know that there
will be people who say david
if you had kids and you promised them
nine months ago that in 2020 you were
going to disney world
and you're going crazy and you're like i
get it isn't there some other place you
can go that's maybe a little safer than
disney world
i would think so and you know like
thinking about these like and
these non-mask zones in particular
really is there like an is there
let me start sorry i was stumbling
everywhere um
okay um yeah i don't think so i mean
kids are not going to be happy with this
but that's why the adults have to come
in and sort of explain what's going on
to them
and you know that's that's sort of like
the least of my concerns i'm more
concerned with like people catching the
virus and
and all that stuff and when you think
about these zones in particular like
these
mask-free zones is there an easier place
to catch coronavirus than those because
if you think about it like florida is
the hardest hit state with the virus
right now
and then the people going to disney
world in these early days they're
probably people who
don't maybe don't believe in the virus
like don't care about it all that much
they're probably the trump supporting
types but okay at least everyone has to
wear a mask
during the duration of the day the
people who go to these mask-free zones
they must be the people who are just
completely reckless right i mean like
that that's the place to catch
coronavirus the self-selection bias of
who you is going to end up
at disney world as coronavirus is
spreading
like wildfire in florida in a mask-free
zone
are probably the exact people you need
to be staying away from and i saw some
pictures of what's going on at disney
world
people are bunched all on top of each
other
then i mean i guess their argument is
that in the relaxation zones where you
don't have to wear a mask
the tables are far apart so while you're
in there you're unlikely
why are you going to disney world right
now i've heard no
reasonable explanation as to why anyone
would go to disney world at this point
in time
especially now yeah and i thought you
know maybe disney world announced this
opening this reopening
a couple months ago and things were
looking a little bit better like the
trends were a little bit better we
thought okay maybe by july things will
be okay we can reopen disney world
at a certain point wouldn't they think
oh my god cases are skyrocketing in
florida we can't do this anymore even if
it's on like a week or two notice
you think they'd be able to come in and
do the right thing and i wonder if it's
just that
you know many businesses are at the end
of their runway like they were able to
like afford
the few months of lost revenue uh
because of the shutdowns but at this
point it's kind of do or die from them
maybe not disney because they're such a
big company and they're like the
production company and all this stuff
too
uh but i think that is probably the case
for many businesses i hate disney world
when there's no global pandemic going on
i just don't like it i've been there
twice and it's just i just have no
interest in it but
the the next sort of step in florida
is the republican convention remember
that the republican convention was
scheduled to be in north carolina
north carolina's governor said yeah
you're going to have to like
dramatically reduce the attendance here
because it's not safe
so governor ron desantis in florida said
hey come on down
i'm reading increasing reports that more
and more republicans are saying
i'm not going to go to the convention
given what's going on i would not at all
be shocked if they end up having to
move it again or cancel it or make it a
small event i don't know and trump
reportedly is desperate for some massive
convention rally
i am skeptical that it's going to happen
well it's going to make them look wrong
and i think they're worried about that
right if you had to move it out of north
carolina put it in florida that
already points to the fact that they
probably shouldn't have this in the
first place and now we see
cases in florida skyrocketing are they
going to admit the fact that this was a
bad idea and just do a virtual pres
convention i don't know like i mean they
don't seem like the people that are
willing to do that trump is only now
deciding
that sometimes he's going to wear the
mask so we'll see if he comes around
here
speaking of which so yesterday gyms were
allowed to reopen in massachusetts
and i i've decided and with my
girlfriend
we're just not comfortable being at a
gym right now it's summer we have at
least until
october 1st where we can work out
outdoors
you can always you know find workouts on
youtube and do them indoors
like right now i'm not interested in
being in a gym so my membership had been
suspended
on hold i went to the gym yesterday to
place
the membership sort of like on an
extended hold because i just i'm not
going to a gym right now
it was the first day gyms were open and
there was a 65 year old woman
complaining to the front desk person
that
even though they have the cleaning
stations with the spray in the towels
that no one is cleaning the spray bottle
so that everybody
is going over and touching the spray
bottle
and it's like that's why you shouldn't
be at the gym right now it's like
of course you can't how do you get
around that the cleaning
supplies are shared so everyone is
touching them the only alternative would
be
when you come in you're given your own
cleaning spray bottle that you carry
around with you the entire time my
thought was
you're 65 and you're clearly not happy
with how this is working
you you shouldn't be at the gym right
now like that's why you shouldn't be
here
right and you go to the gym to become a
more healthy person
and if you were maybe gonna give
yourself coronavirus by doing it that
seems a little bit counterproductive
i suppose the solution would be like
those single use
wet wipe type of things where like you
can maybe like just grab one you don't
have to touch the bottle or anything
like that but yeah i mean i think the
the bigger point is that like we're not
gonna be able to avoid all of these
things like yeah you're gonna have to
come in contact with stuff
you have people at the gym breathing
heavily you're going to have to walk by
them
no matter what you do no matter like
what kind of policies you institute at a
place like a gym
there's still going to be some level of
risk associated with it just as a
curiosity the the normal capacity of my
gym i saw a sign it's 200 people
and they had a counter every time
someone would come in or out i could see
the front desk person you know
adding and taking away on a phone app
there were 37 people there including
employees when i went in
to cancel or suspend my membership out
of 200 and i don't know what
and again 200 wouldn't be allowed today
200 would be the normal max fire code i
don't know if they have to operate at
half capacity or one-third
but there were only 37 people there
including a bunch of employees so at
least on day one it didn't seem that
many people were going
yeah you'd think that maybe day one
would see a lot of people because people
are just
itching to work out yeah so you'd think
it would be flooded on that first day
and that probably also wouldn't be uh
the best uh pr for them like if the gym
is already
crowded to the point where it's not safe
on day one that's not very good i'm
honestly surprised there weren't more
people there
yeah i was glad to see to be perfectly
honest that there weren't that many
people there maybe
in the fall i would return to the gym
depending on what's going on
the good news though by the way only
five deaths in massachusetts yesterday
five deaths is still
horrible but that is a
very significant improvement from where
we were in massachusetts continues to be
one of the few
states where cases week over week are
going down i'm really glad to be living
here right now i have to tell you
yeah i am too and i get the sense though
that like maybe we have to prepare for
another shutdown maybe we have to like
treat
this instance now like we did in like
the middle of march where we saw that
the virus was hitting other parts
of the world and yeah you'd come here
very very soon so we actually take
precautions
we're in the same situation now except
instead of having to worry about it
coming from china or europe we have to
worry about it coming from florida and
texas yeah so like what do you think we
should do i mean certainly i think that
the indoor dining thing is is happening
too early yeah i don't think gym should
be open right now
uh so there are those sorts of like low
hanging fruit things but do you think we
have to like get um get ready to like go
into lockdown again what do you think
i think we have to be emotionally
prepared for the reality that it might
happen
but i think outdoor dining is fine for
now i think outdoor activities are fine
um yeah i mean i just think we have to
be ready for the fact that come
august september you know the cases may
well start bleeding over from from other
parts of the country
hey real quick the chinese government
has announced sanctions against u.s
officials
including republican senators rubio and
cruz marco rubio and ted cruz
because of u.s sanctions over beijing's
treatment of the
ethnic minorities in the xinjiang
province
and the chinese ministry of foreign
affairs spokeswoman
says these sanctions would start
yesterday it's not yet totally clear
what is included
in them but the idea here is that
china is not at all pleased with what
american
some american elected officials have
been saying these
are all largely symbolic things
uh sam brownback and chris smith along
with rubio and cruz
and the commission on china have been
saying things
are unacceptable in china china doesn't
like it the u.s imposed sanctions
against some senior chinese officials
under the magnitsky act yes we're
rehabilitating that from the days of the
russia investigation uh which prohibits
americans from doing business with some
of these individuals
and now china is doing the same to rubio
cruz and some others
i think that this is mostly posturing
like i don't know how much attention
this requires from a from a
policy standpoint i think that this is
just the continued escalation of
tensions
and for the right reasons by the way in
some cases what's going on with the
uyghurs is absolutely unconscionable i
want to be clear
yeah we know it's symbolic it's much
like when uh iran decided to indict
trump knowing yeah they could possibly
arrest him
uh you know it's just me to make a round
of headlines uh but maybe if anything it
goes to show us that trump really is
uniquely bad here because
whereas you have people like ted cruz
and marco rubio calling out the
concentration camps
over in china you have people like trump
who according to john bolton's claims
uh was like basically okayed those yeah
uh he wasn't willing to like to fight
them on that
and i think that happened at a time
before coronavirus became a thing so
maybe now he would be a little bit more
uh you know against what china is doing
because that would play into
the narrative he's trying to to make up
now but i think it really does go to the
point that trump is just uniquely bad on
this issue like so many others
yeah and you know i've seen i actually
horribly
i've seen some leftists obviously the
right wingers just
are defending trump but i've even seen
some leftists say
you know trump really isn't that bad on
foreign policy there
there he's much less of a neocon warhawk
and blah blah blah
blah any engagements we've not gotten
into under trump we've not gotten into
not because trump has the right
political philosophy or ideology it's
been because he's either been distracted
with something else or doesn't really
understand what's going on or it's just
by chance i mean
the the idea that anything trump has
done
right by not doing anything is because
of trump's political knowledge
is is completely indefensible it's just
coincidence
right and he still let warhawks like
john bolton into his administration in
the first place he still listens to
people like lindsey graham who wants to
start all these different wars
i mean yeah maybe trump at different
places has shown good judgment by not
like getting us into this full-fledged
uh battle with iran or whatever but like
he has done some things that could
escalate tensions as well like you can't
look
that over but the other i guess my
bigger concern is
the amount of damage he's done globally
and domestically
so outweighs the fact that you know
you might like tulsi gabbard's position
on foreign policy and in some ways maybe
trump
by coincidence stumbles into similar
actions
that is happening not because of any
kind of decision really by trump it's
happening because he just didn't stumble
into the issue
but it does not in any way counteract
the uniquely damaging nature of this
presidency and that's why i get a little
scared when i see some leftists say
trump's to the left of hillary on
foreign policy it's like that he just
didn't stumble across some issues that's
all and are they really comparing him to
hillary i feel like they're if anything
they're probably comparing him to bush
right because bush
maybe some country that didn't attack us
so they're saying oh look at the last
republican president trump hasn't been
that bad when it comes to foreign policy
and that may be true
but why compare him to bush when bush is
like the worst ever on that topic why
not compare him to
like obama or have a genuine
conversation about what hillary clinton
may have done
not to mention that it still wouldn't
justify re-electing trump
and that's where you know the
conversation often falls off a cliff
which is like okay but so are you saying
vote for trump
because of this because that doesn't
seem like the right path forward either
let's hope that there's only three and a
half more months of this
plus trump's two and a half month lame
duck period
we could be out of the woods in six
months by out of the woods
we're going to have big problems to
solve and it's going to take biden years
to do it but
we could be out of the woods in terms of
trump constantly making things worse and
that's that's where where my head is
do you feel like we're building up the
climax here like all of this stuff
trump's election taking office the
russia stuff the ukraine stuff now with
coronavirus
it's all just sort of escalating and
we're going to have the climax of this
story on november 3rd 2010
20. we'll see what happens does trump
win re-election despite and smoke him i
feel like that's going to be like the
time to really be alive
listen if trump does get reelected
it i i just don't know how i'm going to
react after all this if the country says
four more years i just don't know what
i'm going to do i
i don't either i really don't i mean
it's so easy to say i'm going to move
out of this country but like i'm not
you know yeah i wouldn't be able to even
if i wanted to sure
although i i one thing by the way i am
revising my attempts to get my polish
passport which would give me
access to the eu because it does really
seem like it's something i may want to
have
i'm not saying i'm abandoning the u.s
but maybe i want to spend six months
somewhere else
uh in in 2021 if trump gets reelected i
don't know i'm not saying i'm moving to
canada or anything like that but but
i'm looking back into it and i'd like to
try to do it we'll save one of those
options
for me you can't be allowed to both go
to argentina and the european union
while i'm stuck here not able to go
anywhere
not to mention israel at any time if i
moved to israel i could get citizenship
now the thing is i'd have to find places
that are actually doing better on the
virus argentina is not like the best
place to be right now
israel is having a problem after
reopening schools i i think if i had a
polish passport
i would find you know is it switzerland
that's doing really well where
finland may be and that's where i would
sort of shack up for six months
yeah that sounds like a good plan i'll
be stuck here uh having to fend off the
coronavirus dave after day
all right well i'm gonna look into what
options might exist for pat and then
we'll uh
we'll we'll review them on an upcoming
show that does it for today remember
tonight is the chess tournament
davidpakman.com
chess 8 p.m eastern i'll see you then
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
you